M
ADR O ESSWOM MAK
T HAN
SHE'S NOAPR
OFFENDED, AS
DISPARAGES REMARKS EMERGE.
epG IDABOUT BEING IN
OMAR. OR WITH CONGSS
SHE N OMARWELL, SHE N' A
PACKBACK, WE SHOULD  FINE.
>> Reporter: SUGGEG SHS
WOULD BLOW UP TELEVONLYE
>> Repr:
ER
BREAK, SAYINTH MADE UP, CALLERT.
TO T
ON
THTOR'EAKER
ADDING -E PLENTY OF
POLICY DIFFERENCES TS ON
WITHT THIS UNNECESSARY
DISTRAN.
BUT APOLOGIZE R OTHER INCEND RMR
ABOUT SECRETAR>> HE WASN'T EVENU
THE SUPCRIS.
NO, SOMEON WAS TAPPED FOR YOS ST
TRYINE
TOD.
SOMEBODY OTET BAO WORK L SILENT
>> IT' STOP MENT THTY.
THIS ISN'
ADE TORY.Y BOERT DEFENDED
CONGRESSMAN PAUL GORE HE
WAS CENSURED TG AN
ME
TIRADEINGLING OUT
JIHS
, NOT HE
9NE
AILLION IN CAGN
THIS MEMBER IS AEDN THE IRS COM
>> Reporter: TS N N OMAR CALLEDE
AGT EBZING THIS
BIGOTRENGAHER LINDLIVE MUSLIMS N
SHE DOES NOTCIFICALLY
N THY NON  HER OFFICE HAS FROM
> LES WITH.
CONGRESSMAN,NG AT THAT
IFA F CONGRESS OSOG
PERFORMING -
RTS FROERY REPUBL ERWHAT'SOI
NUM S.
AS CHAIRMAN  ETHICS
SETOE TO ATIONS LIKE THIS.
FOR NOT THAT.
I FELT THE AAILURE IN TREGARDM
WHEN THEY MAKESENT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THEPUDEAL WI.
HAVE
HER OFF TH
VEETHE HOUSELO A BUT THEY DIDN'.
FIGURE OUT WAY TO AUL RYAN, ANDH
IR BAD BEHAVIOR.
>> THE TROLLIN THE POINT,
REALLY MORELSE
WHHER.HAO DECIDE IN UCH ANY OTHT
WHAT AREOUR GHY
SPINELESS,RE ST ONIS?SE THEY'RE
E CLEARLY T ENOUGH
LIKE CHARLIE DEN ADANZINGER WHON
WHO TWEETET
'S, AND THEY NEED TO  THE IF TH.
THE LE IT   FWI
E IS SHE'S
WEW THATP IS ILE LEADERE
BLARTY
AND UNHANGES, THESE
KINDS  COMMENTS G TO
GOINTO SEEI HOPE DT NORMALIZ.
S ART LY DISIN
PROPAT
T  HST S
COR  FRANKLY
TO ALL DECENT HUMANS ALL OVE
K WHATREPRESENTS, RLIE MENTIONE
OF SHAME THATEPUBLIHAVE THESE E
LEADERS.
E WAG ABOUT
SHE WAS A STAND-UP  ACT
WHAT'S EVEN
HAPPENGSPS THAT
SAID IT, A H VOTERLAUGHED.THEYA.
SO UNT TT  WE'RETO SEE THESE KI
>> SOME OF TE EXTREME
MBARE
REWARD FOR THIACTIVI
LA BOEBERT, SHTED OU
THISD AP
SAYING, TO ANYONE IN THE MUSLIM
COOFND
COMMENT.EING AY TO
COSSOMAR, TON YOU
WA.ENDED, BY CALLING THEM, YOU S
, YEAHE SO HALF-HEARTED APOLOGY.
YOKNOW, WHEN BRING
DI T, THAT'S
ANS
I MENTIONED
JOHNL RY
NCDEAL WITMEBAAS DID FARWERED -C
>> T HASREHANK
AE SOMEWHAT AUSE HED LANDISH ,
NUMB T CONGRESMADE A STATEMENTI
WILL BE AUITE A
DONAL TSEWERE MER I